[Music]
yo what's good what popping Cam Newton
here along side Randon Marshall and it
was only right that we come on Truth
or truth or dab catch us in this week's
episode you need to say anything you
don't one finger finger one pinky one
thumb
[Music]
one
hey what's going on everybody and
welcome back to another exciting episode
of Truth or dab the hot one special
where we give our guests two simple
options tell the truth or suffer the
Wrath of the last dab in anticipation of
the big game we're very lucky to have a
pair of football legends Brandon
Marshall and Cam Newton they combined
for over 350 career touchdowns during
their planing days check out Cam Newton
on YouTube for shows like 4th and one as
well as funky Fridays wherever you get
your podcast
likewise Brandon Marshalls I am athlete
available across platforms as well and
they've combined forces for the I am
iconic live tour but today they join us
in studio for a game of Truth or dab
Brandon cam welcome to the show thanks
for having us we could buy for 350 350
352 he said 352 yeah it was actually
like 352 or 353 here's the crazy part I
only account for like 80
something that's nothing to sneeze at
for
Brandon and we had some good years in
Chicago I remember them well and Brandon
we're going to start with you you just
put your Chapstick on First and you
don't feel burn all right Brandon
Marshall is someone who has once fined
$15,000 for wearing orange cleats during
your time with the Chicago Bears I'm
curious when you look back on your
career what's the finer suspension that
you think was most unfair and then can
you give us another one where you're
like yeah I might have I might have had
that one coming uh so it was lime green
cleats and it lime green represents
mental health awareness but it was great
and they finded me the fine that didn't
make much sense was my last year in
Denver Josh McDaniels uh baby boy wonder
comes in as the head coach youngest head
coach in the National Football League
maybe ever he hit me for
$75,000 conduct detrimental to the team
because I wouldn't sign this
contract that he put in front of me okay
real emotions
coming some type of way 75,000 that's a
big fine basically what happened is I
was sit in the back of the room with my
hoodie on and he Ain know I had
photographic memory so I wasn't learning
his plays he didn't know that I would
have my hands folded and have my and my
have my you look right now boom just
like this and then I would go into the
wide receiver room and I would say I got
to go do number two and I would stay for
30 40 minutes so anyways we go through
this whole thing all offseason then he
comes to me offer me this this deal
and then I look at him say I'm not
signing that and then he says okay we're
going to hit you for conduct that
detrial the team been leaving the the
the room going to the bathroom for 30 40
minutes and that's how I got fine cuz I
was going to do number two allegedly cam
on to you Pastor present the most Savage
trash talker you ever played against and
bonus points if you can give us a story
okay Julian Edelman really that's a
surprising name we had played the Miami
Dolphins my first game this is my first
kind of interaction with actually
playing with jewels football is
dominated by African-Americans for the
most part especially at the skill
position but when we look when we
thought back at that time New England
was dominated by a bunch of white guys
and they were good and they was talking
you see what I'm saying so the guy
says the Jews hey hey bro you get know
he's like no bro I invite you to my
house on my dime so you can see my
Shrine who the are you
anyway all right on to Wing number two
cam we're going to stick with you
complex recently lit up social media
with their list of the the 25 most
entertaining Personalities in sports
media I'm curious of the top four ranked
football personalities can you tell me
which one is most overrated and why
overrated Ryan Clark Michael Irvin Pat
McAfee Shannon
sharp I'm not going to answer that
question because it's going to come off
as if as if I'm hating and I think what
Ryan Clark does that's not no no no no
no
got about that who's overrated good
question who's
overrated Michael Irving out of that
list it's Michael Irving I was say
Shannon sharp Pat mfei Ryan Clark D
Michael Irving I love Michael Irvin's
kind of
like that but in doses yeah all right
Fair cam determined not to eat today
respect it Brandon we're on to you you
once named Kyle Orton as the best
quarterback that you played with during
your career I'm curious does that still
stand today and followup who was the
worst wow I see
that I thinking it's a funny yes I love
you Cal but no I was trying to get the
contract I swear goly y should have put
them dog on hot wings in front of his
face
then the best quarterback that I had in
my career I had 17 of them I played 13
years in the NFL uh six different teams
uh Ryan Fitzpatrick like I I could say
there's Eli and and Russell Wilson I
also played with but I didn't play with
them long enough um Ryan Fitzpatrick was
that guy the worst quarterback that I
played with and and and listen Ryan just
understand that there was just so much
potential and you know this you're a
Chicago guy was Jay Cutler like Jay
Cutler should have won a Super Bowl Jay
Cutler had everything that it took to be
you know one of the most Legend
quarterbacks and so it's not it's no
disrespect to him but I got to answer
this question truthfully and so I would
say Jay Cutler because he didn't reach
half of his potential right and you guys
together that was always the dream but
it was fun watching you guys like that
answer no Fitz magic don't get me wrong
it's fun to watch but talented see but
as a receiver smart see as a but
talented come on all right on to round
number three determined not to eat the
wings I respect it cuz we getting some
great stories and we'll go to you Cam
last April you made a list of teams that
you'd be willing to play for remarking
there ain't 32 guys that's better than
me looking at the current landscape of
the league right now which team do you
think has the most poachable qb1
situation
which one couldn't I yeah that's
what I'm saying that's what I'm saying
no you know uh Atlanta walk right
in Ridler not doing it for you he didn't
do it for them this year truth or Deb
are you coming back or not
he didn't ask the
question Brandon it's hard to believe
this but in the 2006 NFL draft you're
the 13th receiver taken 12 receivers in
front of you I'm wondering if you can
take us back to that day and give us
three names that when you heard them
called on draft day you were like I
can't believe they got picked before me
that's real messy no it's I mean it is
like I see why this this Show's been on
air for 9 years like no l it's messy
though you dig what I'm saying I I want
to listen no I can name I can name a lot
of these guys that was uh drafted before
me Santonio holes to Chad Jackson uh to
soris Moss the reality is if you combine
almost all of their it might be all of
their
stats I Eclipse all of them so one to
all not with San Antonio do the math
fact Checker brandan Brendon from Iconic
saga no okay I put it I'll put it wing
on that one if you collectively and and
when was you drafted 97 2006
97 when you were drafted I will put a
wing on it right now if you collect all
those people's yards and you still
surpass all those people's yards all
right maybe the yards give give
me all right let's do it you said it all
right we'll come back to that you going
to do that and then we'll come back to
it so although my career was you know
better than most of those guys before me
or all those guys before me and that
moment I wasn't thinking about that I
was just thinking about myself and was
like yo I believe I'm a second rounder
I'm a third rounder you know I felt like
it was a privilege to be in that
position cuz we were small school at the
time so the answer is none of those guys
well then what I got to eat a wing yeah
you got to name three or you got to eat
a wing right
cam that's how it
works okay let's
go
yeah boy no bro I put my Chapstick on
you
good Plame you got to eat the whole
thing you know you don't have to it's
all about intended effect so if you feel
like that was good yeah oh going back in
so good I'm hungry respect it respect to
it nothing almost I've seen Shaq on this
show c b and all the people on the show
and they are out my mouth my mouth yeah
this ain't even hot there we go crushing
it okay sometimes they have a little bit
of a time delay on them you know no keep
keep keep that same energy guard to B
coming on the show Shaq came I'm hungry
anyway don't to finish the chicken uh
Brandon one more bike all the
bikes respect we are in the game now and
we are on to round number four
cam that's good y'all should sell
these we
do it's a good suggestion yeah we're
almost to the Finish Line cam which SEC
school has the most obnoxious fan base
and what makes them so ins Alabama
straight up SEC it goes like this
Alabama to hell with him obviously I
went to Auburn Georgia y'all had
one or two good years and then let's not
remember that I was the most
underachieving school with the most
Talent LSU can get it can get it can get
real dangerous in Death Valley it's real
football over there Brandon you talking
about UCL oh man let me tell you
something boy UCL we got as as many
championship as you do what
happened I'm just
thirsty Brandon on to you before we go
on to me uh St uh fact Checker s anonio
holes Jason Avant and Greg Jennings what
the three of them combined have more
than another one DJ KET another
one I want you to do three bro three oh
three Jason aant I forgot about Jason
Jason was a real deal yeah I'm going to
take a bite of this
one bro what is in this why is taking so
long to I get I get it it's just it
plays mind games with you you know it
leaves a false first impression you
think that you're on top of it it comes
back later that's good that's good
that's good Jack coming off to the boy
it's hot in there boy on to round number
five you going eat the fifth and Final
Round we'll try to make
him off the uh assist cim are you coming
back um but don't give us no diplomatic
answer listen if there's an opportunity
for me to come back I will there hasn't
been an opportunity that I deemed was
good enough for me to come back I am a
father of soon to be
eight loaded like a baked potato
bro but no and and I want I want more
children that is like I'm I come from a
big family so yes or
no I'm just G you I'm giving you premise
of like no I appreciate the Contex just
eat a wing bro so you are coming back I
plan to come back but it's not about me
it's not about me I've been asking for 4
months you got this on your show
literally thre of hot sauce you know
[Music]
yeah all right and last question for you
guys and you can work together on this
one four teams remain at the time of
this taping but only two will be left by
the time it gets out my question to you
is this of the Chiefs Ravens 49ers and
lions which remaining NFL team will
definitely not win win the Super Bowl
this year and why the easy an is Detroit
Lions but like this team no I know but
that's what I'm
saying Sports let tell you something
about sports we all love a Underdog
Story who's more Underdog than Detroit
for years we love a storyline there's
not a better storyline in sports than
what the Detroit Lions and Dan gamble
has been able to do so the NFL script it
not scripted but it's like it's up there
though
what is the biggest storyline of the
whole NFL this year Taylor Swift why
wouldn't the NFL won't hurt in come on
what are you it's scripted if if they go
and yeah that's right if it's Chiefs
Lions there's 200 million people
watching Super Bowl suay I'm telling you
that's good Kim I bro I I just look this
crazy I'm not this crazy the predictions
are in very much looking forward to
revisiting this clip after the game
Brandon Marshall Cam Newton taking on
Truth or dab living to tell the tale is
there anything that you'd like to say to
the people before we get you and do a
cold plunge no I think that cam should
add these wings uh to Fellowship his
cigar lounge oh yeah they're good but
you got to taste it first make sure I
they don't got no blue cheese bro I'm a
blue cheese type of guy man come on bro
just take one bite for the fun of it
just a baby bite you got
it oh they got the ranch bring in the
blue CH yes yes yes yes I love it you
guys are so good that one look like it's
F yeah oh yeah yeah yeah bro yeah it's
good bro whoa there we
go they can't go in
Fellowship yeah and they vegan I know
it's tuming
too I couldn't say it but I
really yeah dog that whatever you
experiencing now wait minutes be over
here drinking this milk and
water you want a bucket you can spit
yeah dang I went too hard on Jay Cutler
no